one of the great joys of working at
Hillsdale College is to have so many
wonderful and dedicated colleagues and
one of those dear friend of mine is dr.
Ronald post rito heald's the Charles and
Lucia is simply chair an American
Constitution
he's the Graduate Dean of the Van Andel
Graduate School of statesmanship a still
rather new addition to Hillsdale College
which is thriving at the campus and
Hillsdale he teaches political
philosophy American Pluto thought and
American politics
it's no exaggeration to say he is one of
the nation's leading experts on American
progressivism and the progressive
movement and writes widely on
progressivism and the administrative
state for the public Prince and he is
here today to chair our discussion on
the future of marriage
dr. post Rita thank you and thanks to
Matt for asking me to participate in
this which should prove to be a very
interesting panel
I should add to the description that
Matt gave of me the most important thing
this year is I'm the proud parent of a
new Hillsdale College freshman so that
trumps that I think Trump's the other
things here we have three distinguished
panelists who are going to talk about
the future of marriage in America Ryan
Anderson David French and quejaime whets
I will introduce them at greater length
before each of them speak so that their
credentials can be fresher in your minds
as you as you listen to each of them
we're going to give them about 15
minutes each and then we will perhaps
have some intra panel discussion before
throwing it open to the audience and
then proceeding to lunch and we're going
to begin with Ryan Anderson so Ryan
Anderson dr. Ryan Anderson researches
and writes about marriage and religious
liberty he is the William east Simon
senior research fellow in American
principles and public policy at the
Heritage Foundation he is also the
founding editor
founder and editor of public discourse
and that's the online journal of the
Witherspoon Institute in Princeton New
Jersey
Orion's recent work at Heritage focuses
on the constitutional questions that
surround same-sex marriage he is most
recently the author of a book titled
truth overruled the future of marriage
and religious freedom that's a book
that's out from Regnery that's the first
book length response to the Supreme
Court's recent ruling on marriage and
he's also the co-author of a book titled
what is marriage man and woman a defense
that's from encounter books and finally
I think it's important to add that Ryan
was cited by Justice Clarence Thomas in
Thomas's dissenting opinion in the
recent Supreme Court case involving
state marriage laws in addition to which
Justice Samuel Alito cited Ryan twice in
his dissenting opinion back in the 2013
Supreme Court case involving the Defense
of Marriage Act so I think we've got
someone with great credentials to get us
started and please join me in welcoming
Ryan Anderson
I should start by saying it's a
privilege to be cited by the Supreme
Court but you would always prefer to be
cited in the majority opinion than cited
in two different dissenting opinions in
two different cases I know how to lose
really well so what I want to talk a
little bit that the panel's had with the
future of marriage but I want to start
by saying a little bit the history of
marriage so I think we can't really
think that much about the future without
understanding where we've come from it
was 50 years ago that Senator Daniel
Patrick Moynihan wrote his famous report
on the state of the black family in the
United States and Moynihan was ringing
the alarm bell that birds to single
mothers was approaching 25% in that
community while in the population as a
whole they were in single digits and he
was saying this will cause a disaster
it'll be severe consequences for this
community we need to understand what has
caused this problem and how we can
address it Moynihan was roundly
criticized for being a racist as a
result of this and he's a liberal
senator from New York State he was a
Harvard professor he wrote this report
precisely because he wasn't a racist but
because he cared about poor people fast
forward 50 years later to today and we
know that 40% of all Americans are now
born to single mothers 50% in the
Hispanic community and over 70% in the
african-american community
this has attracted the attention both
left and right Robert putnams written a
recent book about this he's a liberal
sociologist at Harvard and than Charles
Murray as book coming up Hart is
probably the best-known book on this
question and what Putnam and what Murray
did in particular was that he separated
the question of race he focused on the
white family and what he showed was that
the same division we're coming apart not
along lines of religion or lines of
politics lines of race or ethnicity but
marital lines the big division the two
Americas in Edwards's terminology
between the haves and the have-nots are
those children who have a mom and a dad
and those children who have not a mom
and a dad and Washington DC just
contrast Georgetown with Anacostia it's
not that Georgetown has better
progressive tax rates or better curbside
recycling or better whatever
progressive government programming you
might want it's at Georgetown has
stronger families and the majority of
the kids in Georgetown are being raised
by their mom and dad and the minority of
the children in Anacostia have that
great gift and when this doesn't happen
that's where we see social costs when we
see increased welfare spending increased
police activity increase prison
populations more or less everything you
could care about if you care about
limited government and social justice is
better served by strong healthy families
so the first thing to say about this
historical point is that gays and
lesbians aren't to blame for the
breakdown of the American family
heterosexuals are it was straight people
who bought into a bad understanding of
human sexuality under the family that
came out of the 60s that came out of the
sexual revolution that caused this
problem now what we're simplifying there
there are a host of economic causes
technological causes and then
philosophical causes I mean look at
economic changes women entering the
workforce look at technolog
technological changes with the advent of
the contraceptive pill but also look at
new ideas about the family so we don't
want to be Marxist and thinks it's just
about technology and economics and want
to be hug aliens I think it's just about
the ideas we want to be a resilience and
see that it's both about the form and
the matter and Aristotle's way of
thinking about this and so one of those
aspects that there were bad ideas coming
out of the sexual revolution love makes
a family marriage should last as long as
the love lasts more or less the idea
here was that consenting adults should
do whatever consenting adults want to do
and the outcome of that was a generation
or two with the rise of the hook-up
culture with the rise of non-marital
childbearing with the rise of the rates
of divorce and then the introduction of
no-fault divorce laws a no-fault divorce
laws actually helped explain that
doubling in divorce rates to a certain
extent the problem with the recent
Supreme Court decision is that it
doesn't help us address any of these
problems it only makes them worse
because what just took place is that
Justice Anthony Kennedy took the
philosophy of marriage that comes out of
the sexual revolution that marriage is
about consenting adult romance and
caregiving
and he's now enshrined it into the 14th
Amendment of our Constitution with no
legitimate legal warrant whatsoever for
this
I was speaking yesterday at Harvard Law
School to an audience of largely liberal
progressive students and they were
agreeing Kennedy's opinion is terrible
they said well but but we like the
outcome it could have been justified on
other grounds and they were exploring
other legal possibilities but they all
seemed no one there seem to be willing
to defend the actual opinion that
Anthony Kennedy and the four liberal
justices signed onto it's the best
example of kind of Lochner ISM or
judicial activism that we've seen in my
generation I think since roe v wade this
is the clearest example of unelected
judges simply inserting their personal
preferences about a policy issue on
which the Constitution is silent but
then declaring at the Constitution
impelled their ruling and so it's
appropriate on a constitution day
program to mention the Constitution's
relevance on this issue the Constitution
leaves this sort of a debate the
definition of marriage the public policy
purposes of marriage to the people
neither the founders of our nation nor
the ratifiers of the 14th amendment had
any idea that the 14th amendment would
require a hundred or so years later a
redefinition of marriage to eliminate
the expectation of sexual
complementarity the founders of our
Union and the ratifiers of the 14th
amendment would have all thought that
marriage by its very nature was a union
of sexually complimentary spouses was a
union of a man and woman a husband and a
wife a mother and a father and they
would have been shocked to see unelected
judges somehow discovering in the
penumbra's from emanations a fundamental
due process right to redefine what
marriage is Hillary Clinton only
discovered this a week or so before the
Supreme Court ruled but she's not a
lawyer so you need advance legal or she
is a lawyer both of them I thought it
was only bill but so here's the problem
I mean we could talk about judicial
activism but I think that's only gonna
get us so far I think the larger problem
and what I try to do in this most recent
book that I've written is say that it's
only because of the cultural
redefinition of marriage the hookup
culture no-fault divorce
rise of non-marital childbearing the
rise of cohabitation all the things that
heterosexuals did in the institution of
marriage that put us at a place in which
the legal redefinition of marriage was
even a possibility the legal debt
redefinition of marriage is only
possible after 40 years of the cultural
breakdown you could only think the
male-female part of marriage isn't all
that important when you already have 40
percent of your children being born
outside of marriage when you already
have 40 some percent of your marriages
ending in divorce when you already have
many of your couples engaging in
non-marital sexual relations so I think
it's good that this panel settled the
future of marriage not just the future
of the same-sex marriage debate or
something like that
the question is now what can we do to
strengthen marriage in a culture in
which it's been legally redefined and
legally redefined at the highest level
of our law because what we saw in
Kentucky the past two weeks is what
happens when judges do this rather than
the people or legislators Kentucky had
voted on marriage it was 70 some percent
of their citizens voted to define
marriage of the unit of a man and a
woman five unelected judges threw that
vote out and when they did so they
didn't create any sort of accommodations
for religious conscience states that
head democratically redefined marriage
were able to at the same exact time
include protections for religious
liberty but all fourth of that all four
of the dissenting justices point out in
their dissenting opinions that the court
couldn't do that because that question
wasn't before them only the marriage
definition question was before them so
had we been able to work this out
democratically we could have come to
better outcomes to protect an actual
constitutional right the free exercise
of religion had this not been a matter
of judicial usurpation so what else can
we do now what I suggest throughout this
book is that we should learn the lessons
from the pro-life movement and what I
mean by that is that after roe v wade
forty two and a half years ago there
were people who were sitting in a room
like this thing what do we do the court
has just discovered a right to abortion
from penumbra's and emanations somewhere
in the 14th amendment there's a right to
privacy and somehow that right to
privacy includes a right to kill an
unborn child and all the state law
that we're protecting umber and children
were declared null and void let me give
you three lessons that I think should
shape the future of how we engage on
this particular question the first is
that they rejected roe v wade you can't
find a single conservative that thinks
rohui rohui u8 is good constitutional
law tells a lie about our Constitution
it told a lie about unborn human beings
and every year on January 22nd and the
bitter cold some of the worst weather
that you can have in DC half a million
people come to Washington to March for
life precisely to protest that unjust
illegitimate Supreme Court ruling I
think something very similar needs to
happen the Constitution's not just for
lawyers and judges the Constitution's
for all citizens and so it'll be
important for We the People to say that
this obergefell ruling got the
Constitution wrong it gets the nature of
marriage wrong and it's not the last
word that this is not the last word
about marriage and that we're going to
do whatever we can to restore a sound
understanding of marriage into our law
and into our policy second lesson what
did the pro-life movement do after ovie
wade they protected their freedom they
protected their rights not to be
complicit in abortion I wasn't around in
the mid to late 70s so I actually had to
look into the history of this but the
activists and the ideologue on the Left
said abortion is a constitutional right
abortion is health care like any other
health care every doctor every nurse
every hospital every pharmacist every
insurance plan should be forced by the
government to perform abortion and pay
for abortion the activists and the
ideologue flossed that to be the
reasonable liberals and pro lifers
worked together to say even if you're in
favor of abortion there's no reason why
you should advocate for the government
to force a pro-life doctor to perform an
abortion an evangelical nurse to assist
in an abortion a Catholic pharmacists to
dispense the morning-after pill a
Catholic hospital to have to be
performing abortions it's vitally
important that we now do the same thing
on this marriage issue that we appeal to
reasonable liberals people who are in
favor of same-sex marriage to say
there's no reason
you should be revoking the accreditation
of Hillsdale College because it doesn't
believe in same-sex marriage there's no
reason why you should be denying federal
student loans to students at Wheaton
College because they don't accept
same-sex marriage there's no reason why
you should be shutting down Catholic
charity adoption agencies because they
want to find orphans homes with married
moms and dads there's no reason why the
Baker or the florist or the photographer
should be fined thousands of dollars
simply because they believe marriage
needs a man and a woman that part of
pluralism part of diversity part of
Tolerance use every liberal PC buzzword
in the book is about coexistence another
liberal PC buzzword but we can hold them
to their own principles and I think we
can actually appeal to the more
reasonable liberals that they're
activists and their ideologue are going
way too far now one of the best-known
cases involves a 70 year old grandmother
she's had gay employees she was selling
flowers to a particular gay couple for a
decade it was only when they asked for
same-sex wedding flowers that she had to
sit down with them and say I can't do
this I'm an evangelical this would
violate my beliefs about the nature of
marriage and I can't use my god-given
talents to celebrate a lie about God's
institutions of marriage in a
pluralistic tolerant society we can let
this florist live by her conscience and
in fact it's what the First Amendment
requires of us and so I think we're
gonna have to work on that second prong
or the last prong and I think this is
where the other two speakers will focus
the most and so I will probably say the
least right now about it is that we have
to do what the pro-life movement did and
bear witness to the truth over the long
haul this issue will not be one with the
next vote in Congress it will not be one
with the next election of the 2016
election cycle this will be something
that your children and your children's
children will still be working out and
so just like the pro lifers have now for
42 years
committed themselves to building a
culture of life we have to commit
ourselves to building a culture of
marriage and this is what the original
marriage movement was about in the 80s
and the 90s when scholars and activists
got together to launch something called
to the marriage movement
it wasn't about same-sex anything
in the 80s and 90s same-sex marriage
wasn't even plausible to most scholars
and activists the worth of people like
Maggie Gallagher and David Blankenhorn
and the u.s. Catholic Bishops and many
others was about strengthening intact
married families with moms and dads so
that kids will be raised by their mom
and dad we need to do that we need to
find creative ways of doing that even in
a legal culture in which the truth has
been overboard and I think the starting
point for that is gonna be for us to
live it out in our own families so I'll
just close with this idea
Pope Benedict a world-class intellectual
world-class theologian and philosopher
debated a Hamas probably the leading
European intellectual of their age but
he's he's like the John Rawls of Europe
he's famous for saying it's not the
arguments of the philosophers and the
theologians that convert people it's the
lives of the Saints and so what I would
close with is a suggestion here is that
had we been living out the truth about
marriage a permanent exclusive
monogamous union of man and woman
husband and wife mother and father for
the past 50 years Anthony Kennedy would
have never redefined marriage and so if
we want to build a healthy marriage
culture we'll need to start in each and
every one of our own homes Hillsdale
College students other college students
what going on on your campuses right now
is it preparing you to live fidelity in
a lifelong committed bond to your
husband or wife or is it the hook-up
culture we know that Hillsdale was much
better on that particular question than
most other college campuses what's going
on at the high school level what's going
on in our own communities and so with
that I'm out of time and thank you
Thank You Ryan we're not gonna hear from
David French David French is an attorney
writer and veteran of the Iraq war he's
a graduate of Harvard Law School and a
former lecturer at Cornell Law School
David is also a contributor to National
Review and the co author most recently
of a number one New York Times
bestseller the rise of Isis a threat we
can't ignore a winner of the American
Conservative Union z-- Ronald Reagan
award David is also a major in the
United States Army Reserve and he
deployed to Iraq in 2007 with a 3rd
Armored Cavalry Regiment where he was
awarded the Bronze Star please join me
in welcoming David French
so this panel isn't about Isis all right
new notes I'm gonna begin with a
proposition that should be at this point
about as well-established as any
proposition is in social science and
that proposition is that an intact
mother-father family is the most
conducive social arrangement for human
flourishing of all of the social
arrangements the mind of man has
conceived yet in this nation or in the
history of nations before this nation
and that the social science is bearing
this out so abundantly so repetitively
that if left to our own devices and if
there was such a thing as an actual
cultural competition those who advocate
for the two-parent family mother father
family raising children and intact
lifelong marriage relationships would
triumph in what would be a cultural
political legal legislative landslide
but all other things are not equal in
the competition between a secular
culture that has embraced consent as the
single guiding moral touchstone consent
in the pursuit of sexual sensation as
the single two guiding moral touchstones
of the sexual revolution cannot abide
the existence of a cultural alternative
now we saw this really beginning to
emerge on college campuses even going
back 15 years I will remember one of my
first religious liberty cases on a
college campus involved InterVarsity
Christian Fellowship at Tufts University
now those of you who are familiar
familiar with InterVarsity Christian
Fellowship know that it is hardly a
hotbed of radical conservatism
InterVarsity is a hotbed if anything of
progressive evangelicalism it's a hotbed
of truly interesting and creative ways
of achieving racial and ethnic diversity
in religious in campus ministries it is
anything but a cultural war institution
but in the March of 2000 it was thrown
off campus by the tough student union
judiciary on the grounds that follow
with me here for just a moment
Christianity teaches sin that there is
such a thing as sin are you with me on
that okay sin because this this logic by
the way is airtight I don't know how we
can rebut it sin causes someone a
feeling of that their sinful causes
someone to feel shame you're with me
shame leads to who's gonna be the first
one to say it suicide yes so to save the
lives of Tufts University students
InterVarsity had to be thrown off campus
at a midnight meeting of a student
judiciary without notice or an
opportunity to be heard in their own
defense that was 15 years ago 15 years
ago I remember speaking to Christian
audiences years after that and saying
look I want to explain to you the
cultural challenge that awaits you if
you're going to be articulating a view
of sexual morality and let's pull it
further back from just narrowly the
marriage issue a a view of sexual
morality that is against the sexual
revolution in all of its forms as
consent based morality the pursuit of
sensation is a good in and of itself but
instead you're going to talk about
things like the preservation of
life-saving sexual activity for marriage
lifelong covenant relationships between
men and women to raise children if
you're going to be speaking along those
terms you will already are in certain
parts of the United States labeled the
moral equivalent of a white supremacist
and if you're not now you will be and I
was treated with an unbelievable amount
of skepticism and I'm sorry to say that
I've been proven largely correct in that
prediction that right now the not that
the center left but the more radical
left is trying to drive that message of
human sexuality out of the public school
so thoroughly that it is treated with
the same level of dignity and respect
that white supremacy is treated with
it's treated with today and so what do
we do what do we do we have I believe
four challenges legal legislative /
political religious or cultural and
religious let me begin with the legal
challenge and let me just preface by
saying abandon all hope ye who enter the
federal courts the legal doctrine
governing the sexual revolution right
now is very simple and it can be summed
up in a hashtag
Love Wins okay so whatever the balancing
test is hashtag love wins whatever the
reason and logic applied hashtag love
wins I mean let's look at Justice
Kennedy's opinion in obergefell actually
let's not it's too difficult to look at
let's go from there the Colorado Court
of Appeals recently handed down a
decision in which it determined that on
the one hand it was improper for someone
to deny baking a cake for a same-sex
wedding but it was entirely proper to
deny baking a cake that contained
messages religious messages counter to
homosexual sexual activity so one was
discrimination the other one was free
speech that's the reasoning because one
was offensive and the other one was not
well let's go and look at Kentucky
captain nepotism himself Judge David
Bunning and I say that I as a Kentucky I
practice in Kentucky for a long time and
he's a son of a senator and it's a it's
an illustration as to why Republicans
often can't be trusted with judicial
nominations he was known to be a
thoroughly mediocre lawyer who was
elevated to become a federal district
court judge because he was the son of a
senator I remember distinctly that round
of digit judicial appointments three of
the appointments that were made one was
on merit - based on relationships to
senators this is what you get you have a
judge insecure in his own authority
faced with a menu of options to deal
with a conscientious objector to
marriage and immediately races to the
trakone 'i'm throwing someone in jail
when there were fines as an option there
was impeachment as an option there were
state processes as a stateless judicial
process as an option off to jail hashtag
Love Wins so let's not look to the
courts here as a solution to our
problems what about the legislators
there's an awful lot of people talking
about different forms of legislation
that can protect religious conscience
are they worth pursuing yes should we
put our hopes in them no why well for
one thing every single piece of
legislature of legislation that has
passed is going to be judged by federal
courts they're going to evaluate
evaluate that legislation under what
doctrine hashtag love wins so how many
of those pieces of legislation are going
to survive the process of judicial
review and not so many perhaps some will
they're worth pursuing and if worth
pursuing if nothing else for a symbolic
rejection of judicial supremacy we need
to have governors and legislatures
around the country essentially at least
symbolically raising them majestically
raising the middle finger to judicial
supremacy at least enforced until
they're forced to gently take the finger
back down again but it's worth it as a
symbolic move if nothing else is an
expression of dissent and yes some of
these pieces of legislation will survive
the process of judicial challenge and
will protect religious freak for example
one of the areas that's most likely that
could be most fruitful for legislation
is legislating protections for
accreditation and tax exemptions for
religious institutions for religious
colleges I think that should be a
priority to protect as much as possible
the autonomy of religious and
specifically religious institutions
what about cultural cultural challenges
now I'm gonna be wildly blindly absurdly
optimistic here and saying the cultural
challenge is not insurmountable okay
whoa they're not insurmountable are you
kidding this culture No
it's not insurmountable look the left
has done a tremendous job of winning
over this broad middle to the I dare
idea of human sexuality there's a couple
of things that they have going for them
one is well you know they've got the
hoof sex is fine message going on that's
kind of tough to counter you know I've
been on college campuses and and I've
had debates over these kinds of issues
and and you know my opponent will get up
there and essentially do the debating
equivalent of raising a red solo cup
full of booze and going party on which
they called you know the crowd is yes
well that doesn't really last as a
sustainable lifestyle and so the left is
crowing an awful lot over the fact
through things like sitcoms Modern
Family before that Will and Grace they
won over a whole bunch of people well
let me clue you in on something folks
who've been won over on the basis of
sitcoms aren't your base they're a
little squishy other things can perhaps
win them back well do we have any
evidence of that
well after obergefell one of the
interesting phenomenon what we saw was
all kinds of little rainbow colored
facebook profile pictures and so what
happened with all those rainbow colored
profile pictures by the millions they
flooded Facebook with scolding hectoring
mocking triumphalism spiking the
football in the endzone
absolutely showed themselves to be
intolerant skulls what happened some
interesting polls right after a burger
fill this huge cultural victory for the
left and they lost support significantly
why because the left tends to overreach
it tends to overreach and will often do
so dramatically what's happened on
college campuses I just I don't have a
book to promote but I do have a article
that I just read wrote that I'd love for
you to read on National Review talking
about how InterVarsity Christian
Fellowship was the most embattled campus
ministry our most embattled ministry in
the United States for the past 15 years
excluded from campus
after campus after campus lathe labeled
as bigots and haters and what happened
it grew by every measure it grew in size
it grew in budget it grew and reach it
thrived it prospered and that leads me
to the last segment the religious
challenge and this is where I believe we
have an immense advantage an immense
advantage the religious communities
response the Orthodox Malo Orthodox
religious communities response to
obergefell was overwhelming denunciation
and rejection it was not capitulation it
was not soul-searching about Oh what do
we do about this other than
soul-searching about how can we protect
ourselves from the legal challenges
faith that we face and in fact those
church bodies that have moved to embrace
the sexual revolution what are they
doing they're dying quickly
I believe the Episcopal Church and with
all due apologies to any Episcopalians
in the in the audience I'm just gonna
say convert now your church doesn't
exist by 2037
and I could go on I mean in Nashville
there was a a evangelical mega church
Time magazine declared it an evangelical
mega mega church called grace point it's
not too far from where I live Carrie
Underwood goes there they first took her
philosophy of jesus take the wheel they
seized the wheel themselves and they
decided to embrace same-sex marriage
what happened to that church well it was
the Episcopal decline on steroids
it went from almost 2,000 members to now
less than a thousand weekly attendance
about 500 regular attendance lost its
budget the marriage of the pastor
collapsed I mean you talk about the
entire mainline experience compressed
into 18 months with one evangelical mega
church so what the the bottom line here
is that for right now the religious base
of the marriage community is stronger in
many ways and it's ever been
it's interesting you look at the Pew
foundation - this study on the what's
Happ
in America and which a religious faith
and I'll end with this and essentially
what the found a the top line was the
huge there is a huge increase of the
nuns so again you know on you had on
social media all your secular friends
spiking the football dancing in the end
zone look at us we're winning you're
losing hahaha minimal growth in
evangelicals but then some folks began
to dig into that data a little bit more
seriously and one of them is a excellent
writer and recent Catholic convert from
atheism namely Allah Briscoe is right so
path use and rights for 538 she dug into
the data and what did she find she found
that the trends are actually the
following that America is becoming both
more secular and more religious how is
that possible so if you have a spectrum
of people between the all's the people
who are all in on Orthodox faith and the
nuns the people who are you know the the
secular the secularists are our culture
and the sums who's dying out its the
sums not the all's and so we're becoming
increasingly an all-or-none religious
culture in the United States and I seem
to recall that might be like predicted
in a certain book that talks about hot
and cold and lukewarm gets spewed and so
so we're beginning to have a culture of
all-or-none now this is consistent in
many ways with the larger polarization
of the American public what does that
mean for us it means that it's this is
sad that's sad that we're polarized but
it also means that we should take heart
we're not actually on the run as much as
we think we are and then in fact if
you're an evangelical and you dig into
that Pew study you'll find that not only
evangelicals the best at hanging on to
their own kids as far as of all of the
various faith groups they're better than
everyone else at attracting new converts
so there's a lot of reason to look
forward to the future with a degree of
optimism there is a better message we
have a stronger base
the culture is more in play than we
thought and if we can combine those
elements Justice Kennedy becomes less
and less and less relevant thanks very
much
thank you David
our next and final speaker will be
quejaime wits k is the William east
Simon fellow at the Manhattan Institute
so we have the Simon fellow at Heritage
and now the Simon fellow at the
Manhattan Institute as she is also a
contributing editor of city journal
she writes extensively on childhood
family issues poverty and cultural
change in America she's the author of
most recently of a book titled Manning
up how the rise of women has turned men
into boys 2011 a couple of her other
books marriage and caste in America
separate and unequal families in the
post marital age from 2006 and
Liberation's children parents and kids
in a postmodern age among others she has
written up for the New York Times The
Washington Post The Wall Street Journal
the New Republic New York Newsday Public
Interest
the Wilson quarterly in commentary
please join me in welcoming quejaime
woods
thank you um I actually do want to thank
the Hillsdale for inviting me today
Laurie I did want to thank them until I
realized I'll be following a Bronze Star
I just I think I should have been warned
about that I yesterday when I was coming
to down to Washington DC I went through
Penn Station in New York City
lovely lovely Penn Station and I was
stopped short when I went into the news
stand by Time magazine cover which I I
have here and I don't expect you'll be
able to read well maybe you can actually
with the camera there it says is
monogamy over with it bright red you
know I thought of it as a bright red
lipstick cover now I don't know why I
was stopped short
I've been reading stories like these for
decades now the media love stories like
these and has for decades and we've been
treated to titles like the end of
marriage is this the end of marriage is
marriage outdated does the Ashley
Madison hack spell the end of marriage
the marriage apocalypse
the case against marriage here's another
one is marriage finally obsolete let's
hope so
so you know this is certainly nothing
new in 19 2010 Pew Research published a
survey asking respondents is marriage
obsolete
and guess what almost 39 percent said
yes and if you just asked Millennials
that is people in their 20s impossibly
early 30s the numbers were even higher
44 percent that report led to coverage
in CBS CBS ABC CNN The Washington Post
the MPM PR USA Today etc eccentric
cetera
the BBC didn't ask is a marriage
obsolete they asked is marriage outdated
same same thing I guess that's the
British ISM they don't use obsolete and
I you know we hear this kind of talk
everywhere all the time and as Ryan said
earlier and I quite agree with him this
is something that heterosexuals have
caused it to happen from my you know
certainly from my point of view as well
is the is monogamy over though
how could the answer be anything but yes
as president president Arn asked earlier
this morning is anyone here not worried
well we're all worried but I think we
have to be careful not to go too fast
down that road I'm a conservative as a
conservative I think of human
institutions and I include marriage as
fragile and I think of human beings as
well not angels in fact they can be
fickle and vain so I would be inclined
to think that the expressions of gloom
must be right that perhaps we are
reaching a point of no return but I
don't or at least I'm not not quite
there yet and I want to explain why I
mean David says this the problem is the
problems concerning marriage marriage
are not insurmountable at the moment I
agree but I'll probably change my mind
before I reach the end of my comments
and they're not that long now let's
start with some of the bad news you've
heard some of it already you know some
of it but let me let me repeat it anyway
because these numbers are just so
incredible in nineteen sixty-five
percent of American children were born
to unmarried mothers five percent it was
a non-problem
today 41% as Ryan said those numbers are
particularly high among blacks 72% of
black children are buoyed to single
mothers about 50% of Hispanics and
around 24% of whites that 24 percent
number today is about where things were
when point point for blacks when more
Nahan wrote his famous or infamous
report warning of an impending crisis
now you'll often hear SPECT skeptics
respond very hopefully to these numbers
by saying well many of those parents are
actually cohabiting who says they have
to be married to be to be decent parents
but we know in the United States and any
at any rate seems to be somewhat
different in Europe we know that in the
United States those cohabiting
relationships are extremely fragile and
though kids who are born to cohabiting
parents are three times as likely to see
those parents break up before their
third birthday and many more before
their fifth birthday fewer than half
that is 46 percent of children under 18
are in a home with their two married
biological parents that that is in
opposition to 73 percent in 1960 34
percent of children are growing up with
a single parent
that's versus 9 percent in 1960 so these
are very alarming numbers one of the
biggest problems with these numbers I
believe is that the collapse of marriage
among certain groups at any rate has
increased poverty and inequality and led
to a decreased chances of getting ahead
of of upward mobility
and this seems to me to be especially a
problem today in a very competitive and
globalized economy single parents the
children of single-parent families are
three times as likely to be poor as
married couple families worse their
children are more likely to remain poor
even controlling for income and race
their children particularly their boys
have more behavior problems which
reduces their chances of doing well in
school which as I said as I implied a
moment ago in a competitive globalized
economy is a spells future problems
here's the good news you ready we're
ready for some good news
such as it is so first this decline in
the number of children growing up with
single parents or with being born to
married parents that's the number I'm
focusing on here actually plateaued in
the mid 90s and may have even declined
just a smidgen and it has remained
somewhat stable for the last few years
so are we about to face something
different a new trend - soon to say but
at least it's not getting worse the
other piece of good news which I'll
modify of course because all good news
since never as good as it seems in this
business the problem of family breakdown
has actually come out of the closet
after a long period of denial social
scientists began to reach a consensus in
the late 1990s that in fact the children
of single mothers were doing worse than
the children of married mothers on just
about every measure
they studied school achievement poverty
motional well-being drug used to link
win' see and graduation rates it's true
that not everyone is convinced but in
the Academy
in the policy circles people know what
has happened and they're finally willing
to admit it
here's Princeton University is just to
give you one example
here's Princeton University sociologist
Sarah McClanahan liberal as far as I
know and someone who is highly respected
in her field
but also one of the bravest voices in
this area she's been writing about it
for a long time and she's listened to so
here's what she wrote fairly recently
children growing up with a single mother
are doubly disadvantaged they spend less
time and receive less money from their
biological fathers and their mothers are
also likely to earn less than their
married mothers are children born to
unmarried parents fare worse on a wide
variety of measures some of which I just
read to you so that's the good news
minor as it is but with public awareness
about the diminished prospects of the
children of single parents as well as
the relationship between unwed
childbearing and poverty and inequality
with that awareness growing more
widespread and more informed perhaps we
are a kind of tipping point but the
conversation remains deeply
uncomfortable even though policymakers
academics do know what what the what's
at stake here
they are extremely uncomfortable with
the conversation and I don't think that
that's going to change to take their
seats we are going to extend here just a
little bit so we can get get the panel
finished off I told Matt Spaulding as we
were evacuating that he should not
invite me to any more of these because
one of the last times that Doug Jeffrey
our Vice President and I were were in DC
they had to evacuate the Marriott
Wardman Park those of you who from
know that hotel you know how big it is
this was for the political science
meeting there are thousands of political
scientists and various states of undress
sprawled out all over the lawn I don't
mean to upset your lunch by saying that
but I have a bad record with evacuations
and and the District of Columbia so
perhaps it's best I don't come again
what we're going to do is I'm going to
ask quejaime wits to take about five
minutes to finish up her remarks and
then we will have a brief a question
answer period to follow that and then go
directly to lunch so without further
delay okay please welcome come back to
the podium so I believe that I was
giving you my recipe for guacamole when
we were in the only good thing about
that break was that I was able to change
my mind three times so anyway I'm going
back and forth good news bad news it's
mostly bad news as you probably remember
but there is this growing recognition
among academics and policy makers which
are I think is worth worth noting and
and you making use of if possible
however as non-marital childbearing
becomes more of a norm all over the
Western world the younger generation is
going to find it difficult to speak
truthfully about its effects I was just
speaking with somebody on them on the
way in from the from our interruption
who was saying that he's childhood best
friend and and cousin were both children
who grew up with single mothers and it's
a very difficult topic I've spoken to a
number of black audiences and will tell
you that I didn't think that it was it
was an easy discussion to have and I'm
not sure how far I got but so this
discussion is avoided as much
as possible despite the data and if you
want to see a very interesting example
that I'll be writing about actually as
soon as I can
you might read Tana he coats new article
in the Atlantic it just went was posted
last night called the black family in
the age of mass incarceration it has
been already lauded as a as a
masterpiece that's brilliant but he has
not a word not a word about the impact
of father absence on children unless
those fathers are in jail so I think
that that's a very telling observation
and this takes it takes me to the final
concern that I think we should have
about about the breakdown family
breakdown and this concern I think
really will divide us on political lines
and makes this the future more uncertain
even while admitting the serious
disadvantages for children the academic
and policy community are offering the
ambivalent public a way out of the
dilemma and what is that what is that
offering what is what is it they're
offering bigger government they proposed
enlarging the already considerable
infrastructure of government support for
single mothers in 1996 the u.s. passed
welfare reform instituting work
requirements and time limits so welfare
got stricter but in in the meantime we
have a steady supply of programs that
help to sustain the fragile
single-parent household in New York City
those include not just my home of New
York where we are most familiar with the
the scene in New York City cludes not
just federal programs like food stamps
the women's and infants can care
with the WIC program childcare credits
Head Start Medicare SSI but also public
housing disproportionately occupied by
single parents single parent households
special education programs also
disproportionately used by a single
parent by the children of single parents
and extremely expensive and
bureaucratically demanding after-school
program preschools and maybe for all I
know
midnight baseball basketball excuse me
we could we could try baseball but I
think it's midnight basketball and it's
no it's by no means clear on no matter
what our philosophy of government is how
to entirely dismantle this
infrastructure even if it were
politically possible or morally wise as
a political matter the entrenched system
of benefits label labeling those who
warn has the effect of labeling those
who warn about unintended consequences
as greedy and lacking in compassion and
this is a political challenge that I
have yet to see anybody address very
well to the return finally to the
question is monogamy over sometimes we
conservatives say that Americans or
emphasize how much Americans are lacking
in values I would put it a little bit
differently I think that the values have
shifted and they have shifted to the
detriment of marriage premarital sex
cohabitation divorce non-marital births
homosexuality clearly all have become
more far more acceptable to Americans
than they were just a decade ago but
there's something interesting that has
also shown up in surveys which I think
captures just an ambiguity and
ambivalence that's out there the Pew
survey no I believe this was a Gallup
survey
they did a study asking whether having
an affair being unfaithful to a spouse
was a bad thing and you know what people
think that's worse than just about
anything that they can do it is the one
area where there is consensus ninety one
percent of Americans believe cheating on
a spouse is morally wrong it's kind of
interesting isn't it that's two times by
the way what what the number was 40
years ago and it's a food for thought
but it does suggest that the human
predilections towards jealousy the
longing for permanence and for deep
abiding bonds is still very much with us
it's a small piece of comfort for us
here maybe but one to keep in mind thank
you thank you Kay in spite of the the
fire alarm I think it's the case that
this panel has been much more agreeable
than the first panel this morning and so
because of that I'm actually going to
see if I play a little bit of a devil's
advocate here and ask the first question
of the panelists now that now that gay
marriage is is the law of the land as it
were I know a couple of the panelists
have suggested trying as best we can to
carve out protections and exemptions for
conscience or for religion and and
certainly as a practical matter it's
hard to think about doing otherwise but
I did want to ask you know is there need
to be careful with that especially since
if we consider today or celebrating
Constitution day we're kind of bemoaning
the lack of understanding of the
principles of the founding and it's I
think you can make a good case that it
would have been very concerning to the
founders to hear the argument that there
should be exemptions or carve outs for
certain groups from otherwise generally
applicable laws and in that I think they
would have thought that about
religion they would have thought that
even even religious belief doesn't get
exemption from laws that are otherwise
constitutional or or or good and so I
guess I would ask the panelists are we
just essentially settling now and maybe
this is what we have to do but settling
now for it for a second best and do we
have to be careful about shrouding our
you know claiming too strongly the
mantle of the Constitution as we seek
special exemptions for religion or
conscience is this on yeah I have a
couple of thoughts about that I'm not
sure that I agree with your
characterization of the founders I mean
there's a debate between Michael
McConnell and Jerry Bradley on whether
or not the First Amendment as originally
understood would include exemptions from
otherwise generally applicable laws
Scalia sided with Jerry Bradley and
Robby George in that debate but I think
Michael McConnell has a good
counter-argument especially from
historical practice it does seem like we
accommodated a variety of religious
beliefs that did conflict with generally
applicable laws especially when it comes
to pacifists and people who couldn't
take oaths and things like that
and so I wouldn't want to be too quick
to say that the founders weren't in
favor of some accommodations and
exemptions but I take your general point
exactly right the best way to protect
your freedoms are not to pass bad laws
in the first place and not to have
unelected judges legislate from the
bench in the first place so you're
entirely right that we are in a
second-best world after the court roe v
wade decision and after the courts
obergefell decision so the long-term
goal for the pro-life movement is to
overturn Roe and to reinstate laws that
protect unborn children in the mean time
they need to protect their freedom to do
that and so it was vitally important
that we didn't allow the activists on
the left to win and to force pro-life
doctors and nurses to perform abortion
and to make it impossible to be a
Catholic hospital the left would love
nothing more than if all of our social
services were delivered by the state and
they can win on both their sexual agenda
and their big government agenda if
Catholic schools are shut down lose
their accreditation
who's there nonprofit tax status if
Catholic hospitals are shut down this is
part of what's going on with the HHS
mandate is it going to be possible for
these non-governmental institutions of
civil society to exist with their own
character and the left if they shut down
Catholic charity adoption agencies they
say it's a two-for-one victory now the
government is gonna be doing all these
adoptions and the Catholics lose on
their moral values so I would say
ultimately yes the long-term goal here
is to overturn obergefell and to
reinstate the sound understanding of
marriage into our law on policy one of
the short-term techniques will be
protecting our freedom to live
accordance to the truth in our own
institutions our churches our schools
our charities and our businesses one
thing I would say going to the founders
point I think what we're dealing with
with the Kennedy decision in obergefell
Planned Parenthood v Casey and before
that Roe is we have a state
establishment of religion from the
judicial branch of the United States and
that in this in the face of that state
what is for all practical purposes just
a purely moral judgment located in the
worldview of various justices over the
years that that makes the Free Exercise
argument inherent that much more
indispensable that free exercise in the
face of potential establishment was
critical to the founders vision of what
would maintain a religiously diverse and
pluralistic country and keep us together
so the idea the notion of of defending
free exercise is critically important
particularly in the face of this state
establishment I don't think that we
should view the obergefell decision
through a legal lens at all just like we
I don't think we should view Planned
Parenthood v Casey through a legal lens
at all this is the sweet these are the
sweet mystery of life decisions that you
know the most important thing is that a
person be able to chart for themselves
their own course and their own
definition of yada-yada-yada and that's
not law that's religion and so then the
second thing that a strong Free Exercise
argument and a religious accommodation
argument does is it continues to
highlight same-sex marriage
more ssin other elements of the sexual
revolution as something outside of what
is proper and what is right and that is
what irritates the left so much about a
Kim Davis because that's somebody who's
standing there saying day after day
same-sex marriage is wrong same-sex
marriage is wrong same-sex marriage is
wrong it's not the same it's not the
same it's not the same well somebody
shut her up throw her in jail we don't
want to hear this anymore and so what
these religious accommodations do is
they provide room for that argument and
in fact indeed even the disputes over
the accommodation themselves so long as
we maintain fidelity to our message and
a modern modicum of courage I think
ultimately work to our favor and and but
to do that and and and to be able to
maintain those arguments we have to
become what I would call informed
apathetic militants we need to be
informed on the issues
utterly apathetic to the shame storm on
Twitter utterly apathetic to what's
happening to you on Facebook Ryan is
very well practicing and but we have to
be a militant and defending our
constitutional liberties and so informed
apathetic militants and one of the great
things is and as I see a lot of
Hillsdale students here is I'm seeing
the rise of these anti millennial mental
Millennials within the conservative
movement and you've got this down pat
they know a Twitter storm isn't all that
important they know they can withstand
it and they know what's right and
they're pursuing what's right I don't
disagree with anything really but I want
to add one one other idea which is that
in the future we should be also focused
on what we can do to make marriage more
possible for particularly low-income and
particularly low-income blacks and the
question of how to do that I don't you
know I've been studying for years I
don't exactly know what it is but I can
I think it's a mistake
to only focus on obergefell and not to
remember that there are many many people
suffering now under the regime that we
start that that heterosexuals began four
or five decades ago and that we should
be thinking about them as well so I
think given the circumstances we're
going to have been abbreviated I'm I
can't see how many fingers are holding
up Matt one we are going to have one
question we have two microphone holders
but only one question will be allowed so
who is going to ask it this gentleman
right here where do you draw the line in
religious acceptance between the peyote
wanting Indians who got turned down the
Sharia law adherent who beheaded his
daughter because she wasn't wearing a
veil and the photographer or the cake
baker who don't want to help celebrate a
institution they disagree with I have a
hard time thinking we're gonna be able
to find that bright line between
religion a prospect's say Christianity
and religion be Sharia law could you
help me so that's a great question let
me let me just back up for a minute and
say historically America has navigated
that relatively easily before what I
believe was a a bad decision in
Employment Division V Smith where the
the where the Supreme Court did away
with the compelling interest balancing
test and essentially said any generally
applicable law is going to prevail over
religious liberty claim we had actually
done a pretty good job of navigating the
difference between providing people with
a wide range of options for free
exercise and then narrowing that range
when that free exercise concretely
impacted the legally the recognizable
legal rights of others so my view on a
smoking Native American is it's no
threat to the Republic it's not any real
threat to anyone else if they smoke
peyote fine
these in in the instance of Sharia law
there's a lot of in there's a lot of
elements of Sharia law and many of them
concretely infringe upon the legally
protected rights of other citizens
including the right to life including
rights to fundamental liberties and
that's a different situation but to
under the perform bells that you hear
about if Hobby Lobby wins if we go back
to the rifra compelling interest test
what's going to happen our country well
we know we've already been through that
for the majority of the of the free
extra of real free exercise
jurisprudence in this country was under
a compelling interest standard the civil
rights movement still occurred the the
Republic did not fall apart we were able
to in fact those years were some of the
more unified years in American history
and so I'm just not convinced that there
is a parade of horribles if you give a
free religious free exercise a wide
berth I think the real genuine anger
towards religious free exercise is on
the left is not from a fear that
something will crumble with our republic
but it's out of a demand for
intellectual conformity that the
existence of that dissent itself is
intolerable and has to be addressed let
me add just one thing today the way that
the left thinks about this is that it's
a presumption of uniformity and you the
objector has to justify why you should
have freedom of the way we should think
about this is it's a presumption of
Liberty and the government has to
justify why it's burdening your liberty
and so as David mentioned the way that
this has historically be done is that
the government can only infringe upon
the free religion for a compelling state
interest in the least restrictive way
possible and so in the case of some
aspects of Sharia law if you're
beheading people that's a compelling
state interest keeping heads attached to
shoulders the least restrictive way of
accomplishing that is not letting
anyone's head be severed from their
shoulder and so we can see how we would
apply that but there many other aspects
of Sharia law that we
allow Jews should Muslim should be free
to be Muslims Jews should be free to be
Jews Catholics free to be Catholics
unless they're exercising their religion
somehow infringes on a compelling state
interest that's being pursued and least
restrictive lay possible otherwise the
presumption should be freedom okay
please join me in thanking our panelists